Florida is now sending more illegal
immigrants these are not legal
immigrants to the United States we're
sending them to Cali Cali and Gavin
Newsom you know we're a sanctuary State
we're a sanctuary City we love everybody
nobody's illegal diversity inclusion
blah blah blah Florida's saying hey we
don't do that so can you take these
people for us we've got some video of
these people you tell me if these people
these are the 36 people that they're
referring to uh in this video that you
just saw the Attorney General from
California and Jake Tapper you tell me
do these people seem like they're really
fleeing the worst of the worst I gotta
get the sunglasses that this guy has
let's put this on here we go there's
some video uh some audio to some of it
so here they are they look like
perfectly you know these are young
people they're doing just fine and oh
look at this they're in a party van yeah
they're having a good time young guys
they look like could be Americans here
they are again all nice clothes
everyone's wearing clothes that fit
backpacks Smiles look at the jackets on
these people they're better dressed than
anyone instead of them look at the
shades on that dude that's right out of
uh he's a snowboarder man we made it to
Cal California thank God very thankful
to God look at these guys at any point
did you feel like you were treated
poorly no no they treated the super well
foreign
you got it guys you got it so
congratulations Gavin Newsom
congratulations attorney general
congratulations Jake Tapper and you know
what you're damn well right Florida is
not a Border Town in that we are
bordered mostly by water and then we
have borders with some uh other states
in the United States but we care about
the law
and Joe Biden will not do his job and I
don't hear I don't think anyone in
Florida is upset by this I don't think
any sane person in America is upset by
this you want this Cali it's all yours
thank you
[Music]